now we have to talk about this
horrible case it's a story that shocks
the conscience even amid all of the
death and atrocity in the world it
stands out and
sticks with you five-year-old cannon
hinnant was murdered in cold blood this
past sunday
while out riding a bike in front of his
father's house the alleged killer
darius sessoms was
witnessed walking right up to the child
putting the gun to his head
pulling the trigger an execution point
point-blank range of a small child in
front of his sisters who were also
playing outside
at the time sessoms a demon spawn
straight from hell if he is guilty of
this crime initially fled the scene but
was caught
hours later it's still not known why he
allegedly
committed this unspeakable atrocity
though at one level of course it doesn't
matter it's a hideous evil
no matter the motivation behind it but
you can't help but ask why
when you hear about something like this
especially when you realize that sesames
was the next door neighbor
uh to the child's father and according
to some witnesses he had just been over
for dinner the night before so i suspect
there will never be a completely
coherent
answer to the why question and this is
the very definition of a of a senseless
act
but now a beautiful joyful child
has been taken from the world most
importantly from his family from his
parents
and the hole that is left in his absence
will never be filled that's one thing we
know for sure
here's another thing we know for sure
the name
cannon hinnant would be known across the
country and the name
darius sessoms reviled the world over if
the races were reversed
a story of a white man running up to a
black child
and executing him while he rode his bike
would be front page news for weeks
and we all know this and there would
almost certainly be rioting spurned on
in part by the incense
incessant coverage we know that instead
this story has gotten almost no coverage
by the american national media and when
i say no coverage i really mean
no coverage i think a visual here will
be instructive as of this morning
when i last checked a search for canon
hinnons turned up
zero results with the new york times
zero with the washington post
reuters yahoo news nbc news
abc news a search on cnn also turned up
no results though google does direct you
to an article
by wral a local news channel in north
carolina
ap news.com does have a little blurb
about it but you have to really search
to find it it's a few sentences long and
of course doesn't make any mention of
the races of the people involved
now i should know i should note that in
the next few days
some of these outlets may follow suit
and and do what the ap did and put up
their own little blurbs if they feel
some pressure for not having covered it
they may just cover the base to say they
did and then move on quickly or maybe
they won't maybe they'll say nothing at
all
uh either way the point is clear this is
not something
they want to talk about so far with this
case
we have one of the most thorough and
remarkable blackouts of a story that
i've ever seen
certainly since gosnell anyway now it's
easy to anticipate the excuses
that will be offered and in some cases
have already been offered
for this outrageous disparity it'll be
claimed that for example canon's
execution is not newsworthy
because it was carried out by a civilian
not an agent of the state
not an agent of the state but ammar
arbory was was killed by civilians so
was trayvon martin
they're both household names uh it'll be
argued that
this crime wasn't racially motivated
which is supposed to make it less
relevant to the general public but even
if i agreed with the premise
that non-racially motivated crimes
aren't as relevant and i don't agree
with that presence
uh with that with that uh premise
but even if i did and even if it's true
that canon's murder wasn't motivated by
race
and we don't know that at this point
this argument still doesn't wash
because michael brown was not a racially
motivated killing
neither was freddie gray or eric garner
or george floyd
or really any of the famous homicide or
alleged homicide cases from the last
decade or so
none of them have had any established
and proven link to racism
yet these victims are all also household
names
now as a last-ditch attempt at
obfuscation it'll be said that
well this crime isn't on video thus
making it less sensational and giving
less
viral potential to it um and it's sad if
murder is looked at
that way these days as content to be
consumed
but i can see that this is in fact how
the media views the subject
but there was no video of trayvon martin
there was no video of
freddie gray and on the other side i
could think of plenty of sensational
murders
that were caught on video yet yet
receive very little coverage
daniel shaver the white arizona man
killed by cops while on his knees
begging for his life
the worst cop shooting that that has
been caught on video
hands down um or how about brittany hill
the the black chicago mother gunned down
by gang members while holding her baby
it's one of the most shocking crimes
ever to be caught on camera yet
very little media interest in either of
these cases
there simply is no explanation for the
way these various incidents are treated
other than the most disgraceful and
infuriating one
the national media is specifically
interested
in fueling a certain racial narrative
and they will make the intentional
editorial decision to blacklist
or downplay any story that interferes
with it
brittany hill was ignored because she
was killed by men with the wrong
color skin the silence around canon
hidden's name is
even more deafening because he was
killed by a man with the wrong color
skin
while also himself having the wrong
color skin
we cannot be so jaded that we don't stop
to really focus on this and consider it
for the horror and the
outrage that it is the national media
doesn't care
that canon hinnant died
was killed and doesn't want you to care
because he was white it is that
straightforward that sick
that evil there is no way around it it
is the truth it is undeniable
the last thing that we take from this i
think is crucial
our reality is curated we live in the
information age but
the information is not the same thing as
knowledge even less is it is it
perspective even less
is it wisdom to have information to be
informed is merely to be made aware of
certain events and certain facts
and perhaps only in bits and pieces but
we have confused information with
knowledge which means that
the people giving us information also
give us the illusion of knowledge they
sift through
the events of modern society pulling
bits from here and bits from there
presenting pieces of different puzzles
but never the full picture
and then we many of us anyway as
americans take all of those pieces and
imagine that we
know something about the world so if the
national media only ever tells us about
white on black killing
and only very carefully selected facts
about those killings
and they flat out refuse to acknowledge
the existence of black on white killing
or if they have to acknowledge it only
in a dismissive way and certainly never
ever ever
in the context of any kind of larger
trend then we'll begin to think
that we know something and what we know
we think is that america is a racist
country where black people are being
hunted and killed
and the reverse almost never happens
because white people are protected by
their
privilege and by the racist institutions
that elevate them while oppressing
everybody else
this is the picture the media wants to
present wants us to see
by forcing a bunch of random pieces from
other puzzles together
the narrative is all that matters it is
the prime directive the only thing that
is
ever considered when deciding what not
to cover
what to cover and how to cover it and
that is why canon hinnant
despite being a precious and innocent
young child savagely cut down in broad
daylight
while riding his bike looking forward to
starting kindergarten
that is why he will not be memorialized
or mourned over
or talked about the way that george
floyd was
that doesn't change the fact this is a
great
unimaginable tragedy and it is an
injustice that commit that commands our
attention
no matter what cnn says or more
precisely doesn't say
about it well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt walsh show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content